After ten years, a Greek general named Odysseus came up with a clever plan.
He got the Greeks to build a giant wooden horse.
There was space inside for some men to hide.
Secretly some Greek soldiers climbed inside.
Then the horse was left outside the city gates.
The Greeks got into their boats and pretended to sail away.
The Trojans were very excited.
They thought they had won the war.
They thought the horse was a gift to say sorry.
Some of the Trojans did not believe this and wanted to burn the horse.
No one listened to them.
The horse was pulled inside the city.
The Greek soldiers waited inside quietly.
That night, when everyone was asleep, they climbed out and opened the city gates.
The Greek army had come back and was waiting outside.
They went into the city.
The Trojans were all asleep and not ready to fight.
The Trojans lost the battle.
The Greeks burned the city.
Menelaus took Helen back to Sparta, and that was the end of the war.